she got away I told you exactly where
she be Aryan Cisco where there when I
arrived I told you they would be maybe
Caitlin snow inside you then you let me
believe are you saying I let her go on
purpose
do you you call yourself
killer frost but you haven't actually
killed anyone yet even I can't go
because clean the penis suffering of man
all you have to do sure the girl you
trapped
Sava Tonya speedforce just tell me how
you did it I had help help from her the
physicist my name is Tracey brand so the
end of episode 19 future flash tells him
the way that he stops avatar was getting
help from this scientist named Tracy
brand future me said that four years
from now dr. brand invents the
technology that traps avatar the Speed
Force for years too late yeah but if she
invents the tech vinden maybe she's
working on a prototype now that's
exactly right so we should find her Mary
and the team desperately try to search
for this nobel prize-winning genius
named Tracy brand and what they realize
is that version doesn't exist what do
you think you mean save you from a
painful fiery death I had it under
control
this is Nate years younger version of
Tracy brand as far as as the world was
concerned she is a crackpot and
so it takes Barry and Cisco and Julian
and HR to really pull out the genius
that's inside so good full-on killer
frost new threads and everything
no more pedal cars car me whatever you
are Frost who we know is now aligned
with avatar and her goal is to find
Tracey brand and kill her so that she's
never able to create the device that
traps avatar in the future you and I can
both regards free of the pain and
suffering of man all you have to do is
kill the girl
hey youtubers were finally here we're
finally going to find out who sabotaged
a haven't build that in any of this
behind-the-scenes so everybody's
wondering if they're going to keep it
for another episode I don't think that's
going to happen because that was the big
deal with episode 19 you reveal him but
you don't reveal him to the audience if
people rioted after last week's episode
for that twist and it would be nuts
after this episode if you didn't find
out but there is a new round of the
blasts ring giveaway I'll just remind
everyone whenever I post my video
tonight all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video there's a really important line at
the end of this promo did Savatage says
we can be gods we can be free of the
pain and suffering of man it isn't that
kind of interesting it doesn't confirm
that it's Barry doesn't confirm that
it's Eddie or any of the other
characters it just confirms that savitur
is somebody who suffered so much that he
sought to free himself from that so he
became this avatar character now there's
still like a long road to travel to
explain how all that took place where
he's from in the timeline but it's one
of those scorched earth solutions to
solving your problems that we've seen
Barry take on in the past I can't deal
with losing my parents so I'm going to
go all the way back to the night my
mother died save her regardless of the
consequences boom you get flashpoint and
even the reverse-flash is calling Barry
a villain so as you lay your final
Savitt are bets with your friends I know
I counseled people against laying bets
against avatars identity because as much
as I love to flash every once in a while
they'll be like a sudden left turn with
a big twist like the time remnant
explainer that doesn't always jive with
the flash comics but we'll see how the
logic works out usually I don't hold
them to the fire too much as long as
it's enjoyable like as long as the
episode is good I will forgive them the
big reveal because they're definitely a
lot of people that will be upset no
matter whose avatar is tonight but the
other big side of this is the
introduction to the Tracy brand
character so I totally love the actress
hopefully she can become a bigger thing
in season 4 it has predicted it looks
like she's filling in that hole that's
left by the Caitlin with a slightly
lighter tone so we have super dark
caitlin danielle Panabaker is having all
the fun in the world playing this evil
version of herself semi evil version
we'll see what they do with her in
season 4 because
earth to Caitlin was pretty dark in the
new makeup job for this killer frost
costume does it look quite as intense so
it'd actually be pretty easy for her to
be this version of the character for the
entirety of season 4 but who knows what
would happen with season 5 I do kind of
love the way that they use time travel
in big universe changing events to
recenter the characters before each
season so they get to be like slightly
different versions it doesn't have to be
the exact same thing every single year
but unless something really crazy
happens to Tracy Brant it seems like
she's taking that female light hearted
spot on team flash that used to be built
by Caitlin let me know in the comments
if you think that's going to continue to
be a thing in season 4 but the cool
thing about her is that she's also a
badass scientist so unlike HR she can
actually contribute in a really big way
but not to throw them under the bus
because he actually did solve a really
important problem STAR Labs
earning revenue using the museum so who
knows what's going to happen with that
but it seemed like such a big project
the first half of the season that maybe
they actually will turn it into a thing
part of the suspense of her character
too is that she's not the scientist
today she's not as smart and she will be
in eight years so they need to speed
that along so there's this threat of
team flash ruining her on the route to
that like imagine them freaking out over
the next four years just hounding her to
get this right
that would destroy any person so it's
just one more opportunity for Barry to
ruin someone just like he's kind of
ruined I wouldn't say he's ruined killer
frost but by Caitlin's own words Barry
ruins everything but she was mostly
talking about flashpoint you ruin
everyone's lives but I think the killer
frost is actually a much better
character than Caitlin snow she's going
to have way more fun being this
character it even though it's a little
early I'll talk about the writer strike
in a second because there was this giant
landmine forest fire that Hollywood
collectively stepped around last night
that we'll have to talk about the
Superfriends Hall of Justice for next
season because they're just going to
continue to be a thing but I don't think
it's going to be connected to the Titans
TV show but most of my flash video
tonight we'll just be dedicated to the
flash so we could talk about Titans in
another video but if you don't know what
the writer stripe was and you don't sure
what they were arguing about it's not
super
pourtant now because they reached a new
deal but what would have happened is is
that last night there was this deadline
that passed that was going to allow all
of the writers in Hollywood on all the
movies all the TV shows to strike until
they got their terms so the last time
that happened was about ten years ago
and it went on for about a hundred days
all of the seasons of TV got cut in half
most of the movies that were being
written for that next year got crippled
it was devastating
so if they'd gone on strike late last
night the next season of the flash would
have been cut in half but there would
have been any writers working on it
there'd be no comic-con trailer there'd
be nothing to show for it this fall it
would be crazy
even the showrunner who's technically a
writer wouldn't be able to do any work
or go on set to supervise so none of
that's happening but if you heard me
talk about the writers strike in another
video that was what that was about the
only reason I didn't do a video about it
is because I didn't want to break people
out before they'd actually made a
decision whether to strike or not in
last night thank the Lords avatar they
chose not to strike so just big disaster
has been averted so what's going to
happen later tonight is Robert Downey
jr. posted a behind-the-scenes Avengers
infinity war trailer for omae's so we'll
do a video for that spider-man's in it
there's a couple funny moments so I'll
talk about that but for my flash episode
so while you wait for that you can click
here for brand new flash and you can
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight